okay you want to get into some stuff you
want about coronavirus or you want to
yeah okay so I'm terrified of
coronavirus and you know generically I'm
terrified you know I was terrified
without information and then I started
looking into a little bit more so they
don't even know about it can you explain
what the yeah so basically there's a
couple of these viruses they're
influenza strains and so the flu flu
yeah so basically a few years ago you
probably heard you know SARS or swine
flu and so you know the very first time
I think SARS happened there was you know
kid got this flu goes to the doctor's
office they're like okay this is the flu
and kid dies within like a very short
amount of time they're like well that
was odd that doesn't usually happen so
they took a sample and sent it to like
the CDC or whoever right like they sent
it to some lab to say you know what do
you see here there was this was a very
unusual case the health deteriorated so
quick that's not typical to the flu and
what they realized was hey this is a new
strain called I think it was like h1 and
five at the time and it was like this is
only ever found in animals this is the
first time it's crossed over from animal
to human and so that was bird flu when
that happened and then so there's been
these different sort of very very deadly
viruses SARS which are which was very
very popular MERS which happened in the
Middle East respiratory syndrome is
what's kind of what these Middle East
respiratory I think syndrome is the what
murder stands for and SARS is sort of
the same thing and so the thing with
these was that you know although there's
a lot of hoopla around SARS and bird flu
like SARS killed less than a thousand
people less than a thousand total
fatalities not a big drop in the bucket
as far as the death bucket goes on earth
coronavirus already killed like three
thousand plus people so already much
bigger than that
the reason it's scary though is actually
and for a while people were like oh
don't worry the fatality rate is low
fatality rates like I don't know three
percent for this whereas four stars it
was like super high I don't know I don't
think it's that number but it's like
majority of people who have it died
where's with this three percent means
you get it but you have a good chance of
living but the big problem with that and
the article that I read was called while
you're probably why we probably can't
contain coronavirus why you probably are
gonna end up getting coronaviruses
because this virus is
dream Li contagious but has these
symptoms that are very problematic so it
takes a while for your symptoms to show
up so you have it and you carry it for
like you know 14 days without showing
symptoms so you'll be spreading this
around and not even realizing you have
it then once you have it you don't just
like deteriorate and like your health
doesn't go to [__] where they you know
you're in the hospital they quarantine
you it's like you know it starts
innocent and it gets worse over time
so the infectious period is so much
longer that there's basically no way to
quarantine this thing there is no way
for us to contain this and so what the
article was saying was like ironically
because it is not as fatal and it's not
as bad for you right away
this thing is gonna be unstoppable most
likely case second thing with that was I
guess there's four like and you know
typical strains of the flu which is why
you can get your flu shot and still
catch the flu every year so guys there's
these four different strains and the
vaccine doesn't cover or sort of all all
the different variations and and so this
guy's case was that most likely this is
now just a fifth annual you know strain
that we're gonna have to live with and
it's just gonna suck it's a very very
you know kind of a downer also I'm sure
you know sort of the bio nerds out there
gonna be like you know there's 15
million strains that's right but like
that's the summary that I took away and
if you want to just get the point that's
the point and so what you have up here
is d2c stuff so like my I looked at my
portfolio yesterday as a [__] so lost
money yesterday off the stock market so
crazy shit's happening all around so
generically stock market you know people
get paranoid bonds you know people flee
to bond stock goes down that sort of
thing other funny stuff happening you
know zoom the conferencing software so
the stock ticker zoom goes up 50 percent
today
but wait there's more it's the stock
ticker zero om but that's not zooms
actual handle zooms actual handle is ZM
so people are buying the wrong stock
because they think people are gonna be
working from home and teleconferencing
in and so they're buying zoom which does
something else altogether
so my small cam stock I don't know Henry
check what the stock 4 zom actually does
and it just tiny stocks I would jump 50
percent today and
you know but you could actually predict
this because this happened also at the
IPO whoever bought zoom the other thing
got his huge pop at zooms IPO because of
this so we could have predicted this one
I love when that happened but all kinds
of [__] up things some other things
smart friends are basically saying hey
if you need percents my smart friends
you know people who actually read the
real information and like understand how
the world works they were like hey if
you need prescription drugs you should
start stockpiling because most of its
coming from China and the supply chain
globally is [__] and like the world
doesn't have that like friend friend of
a friend basically how the [__] do you
stockpile prescription meds basically
buy up buyer refills and and so the
there's no global plan B for what
happens if China gets sick or slowed
down we don't have another like supply
chain and so all kinds of things are
suffering and I have friends that have
d2c companies that buy their [__] their
back tuna and they're saying [__] yeah
months months backed up I was talking to
a supplier yesterday and he was like
even if we come back to work there's you
know all the other factories that we
depend on the printing factory the
packaging guys and they're not coming
like the workers are just not coming
back because in most factories in China
the workers don't actually live in that
city permanently so for Chinese New Year
which is when this happened so Chinese
New Year's a month long holiday yeah
well we have they all Chinese intern he
told us all about it he goes he goes
it's the largest travel day in the world
right because every Chinese person
everybody goes home and when they go
home they go back to very rural areas
and already there's this problem where
they don't cut me and often they don't
come back as you know they don't want to
be living in some other city working in
a factory but with this people are just
not coming back and so there's no
replacements it's like a very dire
situation well and like obviously at a
human level also incredibly dire
situation so to turn [__] into gold
where's the opportunity here I mean
what's gonna happen do you think that
this is gonna impact a lot have
long-term impact with China China making
[__] and you have to go elsewhere
I don't know so there's a question of
like so two two theories one is for
stuff like this the people who are gonna
do really well they didn't start now
they started something too
years ago a blog on being a prepper or
whatever and today's your day you know
like this is your month and so I don't
think the I don't know how much I am
interested in sort of like today
opportunity also feels kind of [__] up
we talked about Judy the other day right
the Judy sort of survival of their bags
my friend Joe speiser bought something
from like survivor kit calm and he got
an email from them saying we have a
hundred times our normal volume we
apologized but we're gonna make it
happen right so those the Judy thing
that which the respiratory of demand
those are not on the Judy bag but the
respiratory masks are just like out of
stock you can't get them and that's like
the thing you need is like to protect
your nose I'm a long gone no one can
pounce on that yeah we covered this guy
who launched a company called Judy yeah
Judy it's a emergency kit yep an orange
like emergency backpack ready big my
wife texted me today and said what's
going buy a bunch of stuff I feel the
same way more people are doing this have
you ever been in an emergency situation
by the way have you ever like been in a
city when like a flood happens or
anything like that it's really bizarre
how it feels no I was in Hawaii our
honeymoon there was a hurricane in
Hawaii oh I wake up a honeymoon when I
was there and so we went to the grocery
store we're first we go to the hotel and
they're like hey um we have early
checking available we're like well
that's cool thanks because we're a
honeymoon and they're like no we just
have like a lot of open rooms I was like
what's going on they're like well you
have you seen the weather report like
there's our hurricane this week of
course I don't take the weather so I
booked my honeymoon on a hurricane week
and so we go to the grocery store and
it's like the zombie attack has happened
like all the water bottles are gone like
the shelves are empty people are just
checking out like four carts worth it's
really like it's an odd eerie eerie
feeling when that happens
[Music]